we got some Tim casters big news
everybody I know our libertarian guests
are really excited to hear meta has
reinstated Trump's Facebook and
Instagram with heightened penalties
other public figures with accounts are
reinstated from suspensions related to
civil unrest will also face similar
penalties but there it is everybody Maga
man is back Donald Trump can now post on
Facebook and Instagram and he should and
he should also be on Twitter will he or
I don't know man I think I think he's
got a contract with truth social that
says he can't for a certain period of
time or something like that because I
want to be clear Trump his social media
presence was by far my favorite thing
about him like he was I loved his
Twitter I loved how he talked about it
you don't say Reed you don't say I'm
going to take him you're kidding right
it's kind of like Tim was bringing up
earlier with a if he hadn't had his like
weights and don't I'm not saying he's a
perfect guy I'm not saying he's like Ron
Paul or something but if he did if
government is a perfect guy yeah well
not perfect but he's the closest idea of
a politician I can think of but if he
wasn't weighed down if the government
didn't government it'd be super awesome
yes the incentive this point a certain
way and like it was if you like for
example I think if like a Ron Paul got
in office I think it would probably be a
similar thing either he'd take a ride
down in Dallas or he would end up you
know some way being tied down this way
or that to where he wasn't really able
to get the things he done what he wanted
done the same way Trump was because
there's certain incentives in place when
you start rocking the boat it doesn't
work out well usually yeah you got to
have the American population rock the
boat for you and then you just make sure
that you don't veto their changes when
they rock it to where it needs to be
rocked to uh but if you go up there and
try to become the president make all the
changes yourself you're just an easy
target
I mean I honestly don't have any faith
at all like the in politics in general
but especially at a federal level I
think once you get down more local you
get more to where you can actually have
uh results even down to the individual I
think as an individual you can make your
life better more than you can fix the
federal government you you don't think
Trump is perfect no have you not seen
his body when he's golfing it's true
very bigly he might be the most healthy
president ever too too healthy the
healthiest too healthy yeah he had to
get he had to he had to slow down fatten
up for the role
I do miss him I mean I'm glad that like
we're starting to see him more um and I
mean I I I just loved the comedic value
he brought to everything it was so much
fun he initiated clown world I'm really
much fun I want to meet him because I'm
tired of talking about him like a third
person Donald come on the show and what
doesn't he own truth social so how could
he did he sign you guys got to get uh my
friend Eric Jackman on here he does the
perfect Trump impersonations you got to
check check out Jackman radio on Twitter
oh God Trump has seen him act as himself
and he approved of it he had him come up
on stage and congratulated him and
everything Phil's seen it it's great
it's a good it's a good trip he's losing
weight though he's been getting in shape
so good on you buddy but he's trying to
emulate Trump's perfect health so
awesome
so Tim you were saying even as an owner
of a company yeah you can have contract
with yourself so I mean I don't think he
owns true social 100 I think they're a
SPAC so they have shareholders and stuff
like that and then in order to do this
deal if if people are gonna buy shares
of this company they need to know that
Trump's can abandon it so the company
says to increase his own valuation he
made a deal that he wouldn't leave he
would but it's not just him there's
other people involved in the company who
say if we're going to do this if we're
going to work a company with you you got
to agree not to go to other platforms so
my understanding is that he can post on
truth and then he can link to his truth
post ah so he can post on Twitter or
something like I called that fat pig out
and then linked to truth and then truth
shows the bigger one only Rosie
O'Donnell and there's like a time frame
too he can post it on Truth at a certain
amount of time he can then post it on
Twitter or someone somewhere else but
he's got to get back on his platforms
man so didn't Elon say he was gonna like
out he wasn't gonna allow just nothing
but posting to another platform wasn't
there something he said about I think he
walked that back okay and and the funny
thing is everyone got really mad at him
about that but that's literally the
policy of every social media platform if
you use the platform just to link out to
a different platform you can get
suspended or get your your post removed
YouTube especially they'll ban you out
right
because people would do this thing where
they'd make a live stream saying go
watch the show on Twitch instead and
then YouTube's like nah you can't do
that delete so Elon says we'll do the
same thing if you're only linking out to
somebody else we're gonna you know you
can't do that everybody got mad and it's
Twitter's a different platform you know
so um truth social is owned by Trump
media and Technology Group which is
owned by Donald Trump as far as I can
tell and Devin Nunez is the CEO of the
parent company but that parent company
Trump media and Technology Group merged
with a company called Digital World
acquisition core in 2021 October I don't
know who owns digital world yeah dwac
yeah I don't know who owns that exactly
but I'm about to find out I love how
like instead of tweets they're literally
called truths isn't that every time it's
so weird I don't like the brand you
don't it's not a verb I know but it's so
Trump it's so trumpy I just love it
truth is subjective like so is Trump
that like that spaceship on the table is
pointing to the left but for you that
spaceship on the table is pointing to
the right
post-modernism both of our truths are
correct like literally that that
spaceship model you see right in front
of you it's pointing to the left but to
you that's not true it depends yeah so
our perspective is guiding Our Truth so
I I don't like that he's claiming that
he has the truth I don't disagree with
your the concept you're drawing but it's
Trump so I just love it that he every
time he says something it's a truth you
know it's just very it's very much the
way he thinks so yeah he's true thing
that's all that's the only thing he ever
does everything is a truth but we in a
Mac we need him back I don't know I
don't know why he's not he's not posting
maybe it's contractual obligations I
have a feeling
he's just not in touch with the bass
anymore so Tim do you think he would win
because I've been amazed how many people
don't think he would win now yeah I'm
not entirely sure I mean I see the
propaganda where they claim that Joe
Biden would beat him by eight points but
I just roll my eyes at that I'm not sure
it matters if it's Trump or ham sandwich
so long as ballot harvesting and
Universal mail and voting is the is the
Machine by which we're determining our
elections in 2016 he was a wrench in the
in the spokes of the transition of the
liberal world order to the New World
Order like he got us out of
trans-pacific partnership day one and
they without him even knowing what he
was doing probably he was smashing up
the plan and they wanted him out but now
I think the plan is out in the open and
it's like kind of amorphous we're
obviously not going techno communist no
one I don't know anyone that's down to
put microchips and be spied on all day
by a corporation and be told when and
what you can say yeah uh so let's I
think maybe there's a lot more potential
for him but he's older I mean Congress
want back Gates they were they really
are are bullish on Trump I just don't
think he's in touch with his base yeah
the whole back stuff and then this was
definitely yours thanks I'll pass off to
you but just I don't I just I don't like
I mean I'm not a republican but most
people I hang out with those are like
the I feel like that's the base that he
had the kind of people I interact with
on daily day-to-day thing they're all
like DeSantis you know that's what
they're all about that's what everyone's
about these days so unless he changes
his messaging maybe gets on Twitter gets
rails things back up again maybe I don't
know I don't see it right now but the
law can change between now and then gets
like a really young famous energetic
vice president that could save a lot of
life I mean he needs to get back into
the public space he's been putting out
these videos where he talks about his
policy plans and he's very much been
addressing culture War issues but he
needs to just get on Twitter and that's
a tough thing you know Elon Musk buys
Twitter I'm sure Elon is like please
Trump come back because it's gonna it's
gonna set the platform on fire and like
in a good way it's going to light it up
Trump's got to get out there and post
those those tweets where he calls Coke
garbage yeah remember that one I'll
still keep drinking that garbage though
that's that's that's that's what we want
to see he needs to be Trump trump needs
to be Trump on Twitter he needs to be he
needs to be trumped in the in the domain
where people are going to see him most
and he needs to be the off the cuff
Trump when I speak of my haters I speak
of them with love it's not their father
born after
I love that not having Twitter you are
invisible like even at my level I I just
got my Twitter back this morning I lost
it in October of 2021 and without it
like it's hard to network with people
and the same with his level at the level
he is it's hard to be in touch with the
world because Twitter is how politics
travels now yeah it's you become
invisible in the political space yeah
not necessarily in the entire
entertainment Zone sure I don't know if
I mean Mr Beast has a Twitter profile
but I mean it's all YouTube you know
once you get big on YouTube for cartoons
and making people laugh you don't really
need Twitter it's just like uh but if
you're in politics you absolutely need
to be connected to that I think to
understand
um I don't know man I wish I knew if he
was on contract exclusive true social
contract because where the hell is he
well outside of that there's a
conversation about how do we protect our
rights on social media if what you're
saying is true you can't Network without
Twitter it's it's very difficult uh
technology is being granted to one
political faction to use you know
however they see fit another faction is
getting is getting banned and suspended
how do you solve for that I mean I don't
think you guys are going to be all about
government regulation in that regard
yeah what's crazy is you know you guys
had Jeremy Kaufman on last year I think
who's a friend of mine New Hampshire he
created
Odyssey which was like a free speech
alternative to YouTube and the feds have
been going after him like crazy there's
been all sorts of court cases uh right
now Ben Swann who I have networked with
a little bit he's trying to create a new
platform called Sovereign and all these
different platforms are just learning
from the mistakes of the previous ones
where the federal government can
basically screw them over and trying to
figure out how to work their way around
it but I think that is the alternative
is like making all just making
alternatives on the point we're talking
about with Trump earlier like his feet
being way down same thing with this like
if you're trying to you know create
different ways for this to work use when
we saw with Twitter and it's pretty
clear with Facebook and probably other
social medias well they're infiltrated
with FEDS they they get you know
corporate welfare this that but the
little guys like Odyssey all these other
upstarts they are have the exact
opposite problems the incentives are
driving things one way or the other so
it's like I don't really necessarily
think throwing the government and next
is going to help if anything I think
reducing it would be the best personally
but I mean I don't know it is usually
people do get a brand name that's what
they stick with but definitely don't let
them get infiltrated with FEDS like
Twitter did
I don't know that you can can prevent uh
you know social media companies from
becoming infiltrated with uh you know
with Federal Building
the reason I say is because it's too too
much of a Honeypot I mean the the
capabilities that your average phone has
like to monitor the average person uh
the the idea that the federal government
isn't going to attempt to get their
fingers into into software that makes
that possible I don't know that that you
you get a world without governments
trying to do that and I don't know how
you stopped them well you free software
if your code's on GitHub or gitlab or
something where people can watch and see
if it's tracking you at least you know
if it's the software itself is tracking
you the networks are I don't know you'll
never be able to keep people out of the
network so you'll have feds undercover
in the networks but you don't want it's
the comp you don't want companies
running social media I don't I the
companies can get hijacked so you want
decentralized software packets if they
drop the patents it'd be like maybe
that's another thing where the
government gets involved with the patent
system I'm sure I mean I'm not a tech
guy I'm kind of a tech idiot but if they
dial back some of that some of the
regulation they have there like it makes
so much easier for those for a starting
point for people for like alternative
like social medias and stuff exactly oh
like uh patents because I know your big
thing is about like you're releasing
information in the world like uh I mean
I'm I don't know exactly how it works
Tech I'm a tech idiot but I'm assuming a
lot of these things are protected
between like IP type stuff yes yes so
and I know that's a common point you
touch on a lot yeah I brought that up
last night too Jim Jordan that one way
instead of breaking up a company
Monopoly like Twitter or or Alphabet by
Smashing it into seven different
companies and then giving the CEO of
alphabet access to all the code from all
seven companies which it would be
counter productive counterintuitive you
would actually force them to free their
software code or aspects of their
software code that would let other
people compete I would be completely
miserable if that happened to Apple and
the reason is I want Apple to have tight
control over their products because I am
willing to pay pay extra for the Synergy
that comes when you use Apple products
when I open up my my uh my earpods for
the first time they automatically find
the phone Etc like Apple products are
made to work together as soon as you
open up the code and you you essentially
are just turning Apple products into
other Hardware where the where the
software is is open and people can can
do whatever they want to create software
then you end up with the same issue that
you get with PCS now which is you don't
know how reliable the company that
produced whatever piece of software you
have is or whatever whatever piece of
software you want to use you know how
reliable are they are you don't know how
the quality control is you don't know
what that piece of software is going to
do to other software in your computer I
stick with apple stuff because I know
that Apple controls it and apple
controls it tightly and I know that this
is probably an unpopular opinion for a
lot of people but you're on a one yeah
it's because when they can I don't but I
don't want people I don't want people
getting into apple and saying well you
have to do this and making apple stuff
work
uh taking away the Synergy that Apple's
products have I like the way Apple
products work and I don't want some
government person getting involved in
saying Apple's too big has too much
control so we want to stick our nose in
and say that you have to do this and
have to do that there's two aspects of
like when you're building software is um
compatibility like ease of ease of use
and then a security is one of them Apple
is very low security we don't know what
their security systems are doing if
they're tracking you if they're selling
your DNA they told the FBI to pound sand
when they were trying to get that Terror
the dude they were accused of terrorists
they wanted to unlock his phone the and
Apple's like yo we're not doing it
because you'd have to make a back end
into the thing so granted you can't
predict the future but I was happy with
that result that they told the FBI to go
f off you know so Apple's a big no for
me dog
just I'm not I'm again we we had you
know we got an one apple machine here
out of all the machines because we had
someone who was like well I know how to
use apple and it's just been a disaster
I was like the integration is the
opposite of what you're describing yes
for apple with using other IBM stuff but
if you're no like you can't even like
hard drives for instance it's like we
want to transfer data between hard
drives you could take a hard drive
between any any PC but not between apple
yeah but like apple is one company
versus the eight million other companies
that's part of why I don't want them to
mess with apple because there's all
these other options yeah but then the
hard drive would work between other
computers so instead it's like we
plugged the hard drive and it's like
there's no data on it and we're like
well it can work in literally any of the
various PCS from different brands
different companies different laptops
but not the Apple yeah that one we have
weird problems with they're finally
adopting USBC I think they kept building
their own plugs and like they have to uh
I think Europe passed a law saying they
have to use a standard so it's going to
be USBC I was deep on um free software
last night thinking about like so what
so I started to think about the arms
manufacturers I'm like okay liberal
economic order is basically Lockheed
Martin Boeing there's five of them
Raytheon Northrop Grumman and General
Dynamics but then there's the British
one Bae system so the six of them
together
comprise about 140 billion dollars of
arms dealers five of the six largest
arms dealers on Earth are in America
they are supplying us directly with our
own weapons and I was like would I force
them to free their software code
arguably hell no because and how would I
do that because then you're giving your
weapon systems to the potential enemy I
don't like thinking in terms of friend
and enemy but they do the weapons
manufacturers sure are I'm like can't we
just blow up bombs on Mars to heat it up
we don't know these are actual tactical
games they're playing with weapons they
want to fight that's what this system
they seem to want to so what I'm sorry
no good I feel like so I think there are
times that you don't want open source of
code but when it comes to social media
and information I am bullish uh what
were you saying no I think that that uh
nowadays the the chips and most of your
microchips and stuff are not made in the
US and there's a strong likelihood that
they're all compromised anyways thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time